welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Agatha coven of chaos actor Joe
Locke recently shared an image for a new
title for the production titled Agnes of
Westview making this the third title
that we've had for this production so
far but what could be the narrative
thread that ties the house of Harkness
coven of chaos and Agnes of Westview
titles together well since we do know
that actress Kate Forbes will be
returning in her role as Agatha's mother
evanora Harkness the leader and most
powerful Witch of the Salem coven and
that Agatha has been wearing her
mother's brooch everywhere for hundreds
of years I have a feeling that Agatha
wants to turn her West View prison into
her own coven of chaos effectively
turning Westview into mcu's version of
New Salem because in the comics Act of
the Harkness led a secret community of
666 witches called New Salem where they
could practice their magic outside of
the prying eyes of man and since Agatha
Harkness does have all that darkhold
knowledge in her brain we could be
seeing Agatha convert a lot of the
neighbors that we met in one division
into powerful chaos magic users that's
super interesting to me check out my
full video on the topic for more
information